>> TONIGHT AS PREDICTED YET MOB
IS HAVING A FULL AND ON MELTDOWN
.
AMID A CLASSIFIED BIDEN
DOCUMENTS AND LB LEFT AT
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS HERE TO JOIN
US AND GIVE US HIS TAKE A HOST
OF OTHER THE NUMBER ONE SHOW ON
THE WEEKENDS AT LIFE LIVERED
THEM ALSO RADIO SHOW HOST NUMBE
ONE BEST-SELLING AUTHOR ALL
AROUND GOOD GUY.
I CALLED THE GREAT ONE.
THANK ME GOD BLESS US.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT TO SAY ON
THIS.
I WANT TO START WITH YOUR
THOUGHTS OVERALL ON THE MONEY
PART OF IT WHICH IS BREATHTAKIN
TO ME.
>> THE MONEY PART OF IT IS THE
NAME OF THE GAME WITH THE BIDEN
'S, ISN'T IT?
DID YOU SEE THOSE HOMES THAT
BIDEN HAS ON A SENATOR'S SALARY
MARK IT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> AND OCEANFRONT HOME IN
DELAWARE GOT THIS BIG MANSION I
WILMINGTON TENS OF MILLIONS IN
THE BANK ON A SENATOR SALARY,
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
WHAT I WHEN I GET INTO IS WHAT'
TAKING PLACE IT.
IF THIS IS A MAJOR SCANDAL.
WHY?
BECAUSE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TRIED FOR TWO MONTHS TO COVER I
UP.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
TIMELINE.
NOTHING LEAKED FROM THE FBI.
NOTHING LEAKED FROM THE
PROSECUTORS NOTHING GOT TO THE
METER MEDIA INTO MONDAY THIS
WEEK.
THEY FIND OF THE DOCUMENTS
NOVEMBER 2.
WHO FINDS THEM?
THE PRIVATE LAWYERS.
IT'S BIZARRE EVERYONE SAYS SO I
THEIR RIGHT.
WHAT'S THE MAGIC DAY ABOUT
NOVEMBER 2ND AND WHY ARE LAWYER
LOOKING?
THEY WOULD NOT NOVEMBER 9TH AT
THE FBI BEGINS AN ASSESSMENT.
WHY DID THEY GO IN FROM THAT
POINT AND SEARCH THE OFFICE?
GOING TO HIS HOMES IN SEARCH AS
HOMES?
ISSUE SUBPOENAS.
THEY DID NONE OF THAT.
AND THAT WE HAVE NOVEMBER 14
GARLAND ASSIGNS JOHN MOUSE TO U
SECURITIES ATTORNEY TO PERFORM
AN INITIAL INVESTIGATION.
HE DOES IT AWFULLY FAST DID HE
SAY 30 DAYS OF 40 DAYS OR 50
DAYS?
WHAT WAS IT?
THEY MUSCLED THROUGH THE MIDTER
ELECTIONS WITHOUT A LEAK.
FOUR DAYS LATER THEY APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL THIS AT THE THI
DEMOCRAT WHO PROSECUTES
GENOCIDAL WAR CRIMINALS, THEY
APPOINTED HIM AS OF SPECIAL
COUNSELOR.
FAMILY IS LOADED UP WITH
POLITICS UP TO THEIR EYEBALLS O
THE DEMOCRAT SIDE.
OF COURSE, THEY DO THAT WITHOUT
EVER MENTIONING THEY ARE LOOKIN
INTO THIS BIDEN SITUATION WITH
THE US ATTORNEY.
WHAT NEXT?
DECEMBER 20 ALMOST AT SEVEN
WEEKS AFTER THE INITIAL BATCH I
A FOUNDER, THEY FIND ANOTHER
BATCH IN JOE BIDEN'S GARAGE.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
WHY DID THE FBI INVESTIGATE AND
LOOK AT HIS HOUSE?
THEY'RE THERE IN PLAIN SIGHT.
THEN?
AT JANUARY 5, LAST WEEK THE US
ATTORNEY HE HAS HIS REPORT ALL
DONE FOR MERRICK GARLAND.
IT SITS THERE FOR A WEEK.
WHETHER OR NOT TO APPOINT A
SPECIAL COUNSEL MERRICK GARLAND
IT DID NOT USE THE NEED THIS
ATTORNEY TO DO A PRELIMINARY BP
REVIEW.
JANUARY 12.
ONE WEEK TODAY HE APPOINTS A
SPECIAL COUNSEL BECAUSE IT THEY
FIND ANOTHER DOCUMENT.
THE PRIVATE LAWYERS BRING UP
ANOTHER DOCUMENT.
THIS WAS A COVER-UP.
AND YOU KNOW HOW IT GOT BLOWN?
THE REPUBLICANS GOT ELECTED AND
THEY WERE STILL GOING TO DO A
COVER-UP.
IT ENDED MONDAY WHEN THERE WAS
LEAK THEY INTENTIONAL PLANTED
LEAK ABOUT DOCUMENTS APPEARING.
THE ONLY MENTION TO THE OFFICE
BUILDING.
TUESDAY NBC MENTIONS WELL,
THERE'S ANOTHER BATCH OF
DOCUMENTS IT'S BECAUSE ON SUNDAY
, MR. KOMAR THE INCOMING
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE SUNDAY NIGHT ON MY
SHOW WHEN I ASKED HIM
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES, YOU HAVE OVERSIGHT OF
YOU GOING TO DIG INTO THIS AND
SEE AND I SAID EVERY PRESIDENT
EVERY VICE PRESIDENT EVERY
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND SECRETARY
OF STATE HAS TAKEN DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
HOME AND NOT RETURN TO THEM.
IF I AM WRONG, PROVE ME WRONG.
AND THEY SHOULD ALL BE LOOKED A
WHETHER IT'S OBAMA OR BUSH OR
CHENEY OR GORDO CLINTON THEY'VE
ALL DONE IT.
THAT SAID, HE SAID YES WE WILL
LOOK AT THIS RETREATMENT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THE REPUBLICAN
TOO FIND THIS OUT SO THEY HAD T
PUT OUT INFORMATION.
IT'S NO ACCIDENT THAT 20 HOURS
LATER THEY LEAKED THIS.
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES WHEN
DONALD TRUMP SPECIFICALLY
ACCUSED OBAMA OF TAKING SECRET
INFORMATION AND OTHER
INFORMATION THEY CAME TO OBAMA'
DEFENSE.
THEY SAID NO 30 MILLION THEY
TURNED EVERYTHING OVER TO US WE
ARE IN CHARGE WE OWN LOCK AND
KEY AND EVERYTHING THEY LIED.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DOCUMENTS.
THE DOCUMENTS IN THE OFFICE THE
DOCUMENTS IN THE GARAGE THE GOT
DOCUMENTS AND BIDENS LIBRARY TH
NATIONAL ARCHIVES DID NOT HAVE
THOSE.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO THIS DA
THAT BIDEN HAS APPEARED WHAT
ABOUT THE UNCLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
?
DID HE TO CLASSIFY DOCUMENTS
WITH THEM?
TO THIS MOMENT, THE FBI IS NOT
INVESTIGATED ALL THE PROPERTIES
TO LOOK FOR INFORMATION THAT WE
ARE AWARE OF.
IT NOT TO THIS MOMENT BECAUSE
GARLAND WANTED TO KEEP THIS
HIDDEN HUMAN WENT TO SWEEP IT
UNDER THE RUG UNTIL IT GOT HOT
THE REPUBLICANS ARE CALLING
HEARINGS THERE GONNA CALL
WITNESSES AND GARLAND
RELUCTANTLY TODAY APPOINTS A
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND WHO DOES HE
APPOINT?
THE RIGHT HANDYMAN TO FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER RAY.
THE SAME KIND OF SPECIAL COUNSE
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS FACING.
AT IS ONE THING STINKS TO HIGH
HEAVEN.
NOW IT'S ROPE A DOPE.
NO LISTS OF PEOPLE WHO VISITED
THE BIDEN HOME IN WILMINGTON
WHERE HE KIND OF HUNG OUT MOST
OF HIS ADVICE PRESIDENCY AND
BEYOND.
NO LISTS THAT CAN BE USED FOR
NOTHING.
IT NOW IT'S GOING TO BE THE
WHITE HOUSE SPOKESMAN SAID WE
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY WE TAKE IT
VERY SERIOUSLY.
NOW WE HAVE A SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
WE CAN'T LOOK INTO ANYTHING I'M
GONNA TELL YOU THIS, IF THEY
DARE TO CHARGE A DONALD FOR WHA
TOOK PLACE AND THAT THERE WAS N
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE BY TRUMP
OR HIS PEOPLE THEY WERE
NEGOTIATING, THE FBI CUT IT OFF
CRIMINALIZED TO THE PROCESS AND
WENT AFTER HIM.
IF THEY DO THAT, THE NATION WIL
BE FURIOUS.
DONE.
THAT'S I